currently most refugees live in the
cities rather than in the refugee camps
we represent over 60% of the number of
refugees globally with the majority of
refugees living in urban areas there is
a strong needs of paradigm shifts and
new thinking rather than wasting money
on building walls it would be better to
spend on programs to help refugees to
help themselves
we always have to live behind all our
possessions but not our skills and
knowledge if allowed to live a
productive life refugees can help
themselves and contribute to the
development of the host country I was
born in a city called bukavu south
seaville
in the Democratic Republic of Congo I am
a fifth born in a family of 12 children
my father a mechanic by profession
what's very hard to send me to school
just like other young people I had a lot
of plans and dreams I wanted to complete
my studies get a nice job marry and have
my own children and support my family
but this didn't happen
whoa in my homeland forced me to flee to
Uganda in 2008 nine years ago my family
joined a steady exodus of refugees who
settled in Uganda capital Kampala in my
country I lived already in the city and
we felt compiler was much better than a
refugee camp refugees in the cities have
always been denied international
assistance even after their recognition
by Yunus year in 1997 in addition to the
poverty problem we were converted with
as the local urban poor we were facing
challenges due to our refugee status
such as
language barrier in Congo the official
language is French but in Uganda it is
English we didn't have access to
education and health we were exposed to
harassment exploitation intimidation and
discrimination humanitarian
organizations mostly focused on the
formal settlement in rural area and
there was nothing in place for us but we
didn't want handouts we wanted to work
and support ourselves I joined my other
two colleague exile set up an
organization to support other refugees
yarid young African refugees for
integral development began as a
conversation within the Congolese
community we asked the community how
they could organize themselves to solve
these challenges the yarid programs for
support evolved in stages progressing
from soccer community to English
language to selling livelihood the
soccer changed the energy of employed
youth and connected people from
different communities the free English
classes helped empower people to engage
with the Uganda community allowing them
to get to know their neighbors and sell
where's vocational training program
offered level hood skills with them
important opportunities for economic
self-reliance we've seen so many
families become self-sustaining we've
seen who no longer need our help
as Jared's programs has expanded it has
included an increasing range of
nationalities Congolese Rwandan
Burundian Somalis Ethiopians South
Sudanese today Jarrod's has supported
over 3,000 refugees across Kampala and
continued supporting more refugees want
empowerment notes handouts we know our
community better than anyone we
understand the challenges and the
opportunities we face to become
self-reliant I know better than anyone
that initiative created by refugees work
they need to be internationally
recognized and supported give us the
support we deserve and we will pay you
back with interest
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]